attention il y a une très très grosse
différence entre le S23 et le S23 plus
et d'ailleurs une très grosse différence
entre les S23 en fait je vais faire un
petit récapitulatif pour vous expliquer
quels sont ces différences il y en a une
qui est très significative personne ne
vous en passe parce que personne ne vous
en parlera donc moi je vous en parle je
vous explique pourquoi parce que je suis
un mec à la cool et que je vous aime ça
c'est bien vous êtes prêts allez on y va
[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que samsung
vient de présenter ces nouveaux
smartphones haut de gamme très haut de
gamme la gamme S pour l'année 2023 avec
d'un côté le S23 avec de l'autre côté le
s23+ de l'autre côté le S23 ultra déjà
publié une vidéo sur ma chaîne pour vous
présenter mes premières photos je fais
la première prise en main mais mes
premières photos qui sont faites avec le
Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra je vous invite
à aller voir la vidéo sur ma chaîne
c'est très riche d'enseignements il y a
beaucoup de choses dedans donc allez
voir parce que ce smartphone il est
super cool très belle promesse bref je
vous invite vraiment à venir le voir et
à découvrir cette vidéo elle est sur ma
chaîne c'est très très cool mais je
voulais vous parler d'un truc qui est
très important qu'on va retrouver au
niveau des galaxies S23 des S23 plus
bien évidemment il y a des différences
entre ces deux smartphones on le saura
mais même une différence au niveau même
de ce modèle là c'est à dire que sur le
Galaxy S23 il y a une différence en
fonction des versions que vous allez
prendre une grosse grosse différence
alors avant toute chose je veux si vous
aiguiller pour vous montrer vers lequel
vous dirigez S23 S23 plus il y a bien
évidemment une différence de prix mais
pas uniquement une différence de prix ok
alors on va récapituler on va regarder
un petit peu quelles sont les
différences et on va essayer de
comprendre ce qui se passe pour ça on
fait quoi on prend un marqueur on prend
une bonne vieille feuille blanche et on
va venir s'écrire pour que vous puissiez
voir réellement ce qui se passe alors on
va se mettre d'un côté le S23 et on va
se mettre de l'autre côté le S23 + en
fait vous avez déjà une différence au
niveau de la taille des écrans ça ça
vous aura pas échappé l'un comme l'autre
regardez quelqu'un d'empreinte digitale
et j'ai l'impression qu'il est un peu
plus grand cette année c'est une vraie
différence de format le S23 bien
évidemment et plus petit que le S23 + ça
on s'en doute regardez c'est quand même
assez significatif c'est la même
technodal c'est du dynamique à molette
2x là vous êtes sur du 6,1 pouces très
cool là vous êtes sur du 6,6 6 pouces
donc fatalement un peu plus grand donc
là je dirais vraiment que le S23 c'est
vraiment le format petite taille
inconviens prendre à la main le S23 plus
si on veut des plus gros écrans pour le
divertissement essayer ça tout le monde
n'aime pas les grands écrans il y en a
qui voient les plus petits écrans vous
allez vraiment cette différence là déjà
à venir connaitre en plus de ça sur le
S23 alors c'est du 425 pixels par pouce
honnêtement il y a pas de grosse grosse
différence 393 pixels par pouce ici pour
moi c'est quasiment la même chose c'est
juste savoir lequel vous plait le plus
est-ce que vous voulez un écran qui va
être un peu plus petit contenu maîtrisé
qui de notre côté a franchement de la
gueule il va très bien où est-ce que
vous voulez un écran qui va être un poil
plus grand personnellement j'aime bien
les deux je l'écran un peu plus grand
pour le divertissement ça me va bien
c'est exactement le même forme factor
au-delà de ça il y a pas de très grosse
différence de poids une petite mais
c'est vraiment minime donc là-dessus
voilà ce qu'il en est alors il y a aussi
une grosse différence qui est
intéressante alors je vous dis très
rapidement ces deux smartphones intègre
le Snapdragon 8 Jen 2 de Qualcom ça
c'est vachement bien parce que ça permet
d'aller beaucoup plus loin pour
effectivement la performance mais
également pour l'économie d'énergie
alors moi je vous parle d'un autre truc
c'est effectivement la différence au
niveau de la batterie là on est sur une
batterie de 3900 mampère heure ok là on
est sur du 4700 comment vous allez voir
quand même une sacrée différence entre
les deux donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que bien évidemment comme on a un
écran plus petit on va voir un écran qui
va consommer un petit peu moins on va
consommer un petit peu plus ici mais
alors attention on est quand même sur
marqué de 3900 milliampères heure je
pense que là on ira un peu plus loin au
niveau de l'autonomie c'est ici avec le
4700 millions par heure ça c'est pas
important et puis il y a un autre truc
qui est super important c'est la
recharge ils avaient fait le même coup
l'année dernière ça me saoule à savoir
que sur le S22 là sur le S23 c'est la
même chose pour charger au minimum à 25
watts pas plus pas moins maximum là vous
rechargez au maximum à 45 watts donc
c'est pareil en termes d'expérience
malgré tout c'est pas négligeable vous
allez recharger beaucoup plus vite mais
là où il y a une vraie grosse différence
qu'il faut absolument connaître et ça
personne vous le dit c'est sur toute la
partie qui va être technologique au
niveau du stockage parce que je vous le
dis pour les deux vous avez la dernière
technologie de RAM qui va très bien
c'est de la
lpdr 5x c'est la 5 x donc c'est bien ça
me va bien ici en fait sur les deux
modèles vous allez retrouver la dernière
technologie de mémoire ça va être de
l'UFS 4.0 celle-là elle vient tout juste
d'arriver elle a été présentée me
semble-t-il l'année dernière et ça c'est
cool sauf que c'est pas vrai partout
pourquoi parce que vous avez différentes
versions de stockage je vous explique
vous avez ici soit une version 128 Go de
stockage et 256 Go de stockage non
extensible dans les deux cas et sur le
S23 plus vous êtes en 256 et en 512 512
c'est mieux comme ça et il y a une vraie
différence pourquoi sur la version 128
Go de stockage vous n'allez pas avoir la
même chose au niveau de la technologie
de stockage par rapport à la version 256
c'est à dire que sur le r vous avez
exactement la même technologie on se
parle bien ici du FS 4.0 sur la version
S23 256 vous êtes bien en ufs 4.0 si
comme moi vous avez un stockage en 128
Go de stockage sur votre S23 et bah là
c'est plus du tout la même histoire
parce que vous êtes carrément en
ufs 3.1 alors si vous êtes technophile
et que vous vous intéressez vraiment à
ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de vos
smartphones vous comprendrez ce que ça
veut dire en fait ça veut dire quoi sur
deux l'UFS 4.0 vous allez jusqu'à 23,2
Gigabits par seconde c'est des Gigabits
par seconde sur l'uefs 3.1 vous allez
jusqu'à
11,66 pour être précis gigabi par
seconde ça veut dire que derrière ce
chiffre un peu barbare en fait ça va
aller deux fois plus vite en lecture et
en écriture et en plus de ça au-delà de
la lecture et l'écriture vous allez
avoir un autre gain qui va être
vachement important avec cette ufs 4.0
versus l'UFS 3.1 et bien c'est toute la
question de l'autonomie parce que vous
allez avoir un téléphone qui sera
beaucoup meilleur en termes d'autonomie
voilà j'arrive plus à écrire vous allez
consommer 46% d'énergie en moins grâce à
la technologie du FS 4.0 ça veut dire
que sur ce smartphone là sur le S23 si
vous prenez la configuration en 128 vous
aurez des performances qui seront moins
bonnes que sur la version 256 Go de
stockage en plus de ça l'autonomie sera
moins bonne ce qui veut dire que et là
où il y a une très très grosse
différence en fait c'est que là sûrement
S23 normal en 128 versus mon S23 plus
qui est je crois en 256 Go de stockage
c'est ça et bien je vais avoir une très
grosse différence d'autonomie pourquoi
parce que si j'ai une batterie de 4700
milliampères heure et si j'ai une
batterie de 3900 millions par heure mais
en plus de ça à cause de cette
différence de technologie de stockage
mon autonomie va être moins bien de 46%
ici et c'est pas rien alors bien
évidemment on a le sein dragonne 8 gène
2 qui va aider à l'autonomie mais ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que sur le
S23 vous aurez deux bases comme une plus
petite batterie une autonomie qui sera
un peu moins bonne mais sur la version
128 vous aurez une autonomie qui sera
encore moins bonne et vous irez beaucoup
moins vite je voulais chiffrer bien
évidemment pour vous illustrer ça
directement sur en toutou j'ai fait un
petit benchmark entre les trois
smartphones le ultra je descends mode
clé alors c'est pour ça qu'il y a une
différence en fait on voit que le S23
plus et le S23 ultra il se tiennent on a
les mêmes technologies de RAM à
l'intérieur on a la même technologie de
stockage on a le même processeur à
l'intérieur ça se tient à pas
grand-chose un million 203000 versus 1
million 223000 on va par contre qu'il y
a une différence avec le S23 qui est en
ufs 3.1 on est à 1 million 105000 et si
on veut vraiment venir creuser hop là
regardez on clique dessus et on vient
voir ce qui s'est passé et en fait ce
que vous allez voir en termes de
chiffres la grosse différence si vous
regardez au niveau du CPU ça se tient
250164000 ça se tient le GPU 500 5527000
ça se tient la mémoire 171 235000 là ça
se tient pas et puis vous avez le X ici
175 1975000 donc ce qu'il faut voir
c'est qu'effectivement il y a une
différence au niveau de la mémoire et
alors on vient gratter à l'intérieur et
on vient regarder davantage regardez
axeram ça se tient remap ok ça se tient
et la lecture séquentielle on est à
24000 sur mon S23 en 128 donc en ufs 3.1
tandis que sur mon S23 plus en 256 en
ufs 4.0 et bien je suis quasiment double
à 45000 donc la lecture elle est
beaucoup plus rapide sur cette version
là que sur cette version là sur l'UFS
4.1 que sur le fs3.1 et pareil pour
l'écriture ici je suis à 14900 - 15000
et là je suis à 45000 3 fois plus rapide
donc voyez en fait que l'écriture elle
est trois fois plus lente sur mon S23
versus mon S23 plus tout ça à cause de
la technologie de stockage donc quand on
vous dit que la technologie de stockage
elle a une réelle importance on le voit
ici elle aura une importance pour le
gaming ça sera moins bon parce que
fatalement de lecture et d'écriture ça
ira beaucoup moins vite ça ira moins
vite pour la performance globale si vous
voulez faire de la vidéo c'est pareil en
terme de stockage de ton écriture ça ira
moins vite bref votre smartphone il ira
moins vite alors il ira très bien
attention on reste sur du smartphone
haut de gamme le S23 dans tous les cas
reste très intéressant parce qu'il y a
quand même une différence de tarif donc
il faut vivre avec son budget et ça
c'est normal si vous regardez je vais
essayer de vous mettre les tarifs là où
il me reste un peu de place c'est-à-dire
un peu nulle part le S23 ici si il
débute à 959 euros ça c'est sur la
version 128 donc celle que je vous
conseillerais pas et si vous montez en
258 vous êtes à 1019 euros donc en fait
il est vraiment intéressant à partir de
1019 euros tandis que sur le S23 plus
vous commencez à 1200 19 € sur la
version 256 et sur la version 512 et
bien vous êtes à
1339 € voilà un peu la problématique
alors il y a aussi une autre différence
que je vais vous montrer à savoir que
sur ces smartphones et bien vous avez
des coloris exclusifs alors au-delà des
couleurs que vous présente déjà Samsung
normalement alors vous avez déjà la
couleur noire vous avez du crème du vert
du lavant qui sont très sympas et qui
vont très très bien d'ailleurs là j'ai
moi le S23 ultra en verre ça c'est très
cool mais vous avez des couleurs
exclusives couleur explosives sur les
S23 et le S23 plus vous allez avoir du
graphite qui est un petit gris comme ça
qui est très joli disponible uniquement
sur le site de SAMSUNG.com je vous mets
le lien en bas dans la description et
puis vous avez l'autre couleur exclusive
c'est la lime qui a une espèce de jaune
un petit peu vert un peu citronné puis
aussi très sympa personnellement je
préfère le graphite là c'est couleur
dispo uniquement sur le site de Samsung
alors c'est un peu relou parce qu'on se
dit on commence avec des smartphones à
959 il y a 959 balles on se rend compte
qu'en fait son smartphone il va pas être
aussi performant que ce qu'on voudrait
oui et non parce qu'en fait au moment où
je tourne cette vidéo tout de suite je
sais pas si vous la regardez tout de
suite mais si vous voulez acheter c'est
vraiment le bon moment parce qu'il y a
les précommandes c'est à dire ça
commence hier donc du 1er ça va jusqu'au
16 et bien il y a un truc que fait
Samsung et qui est vachement cool c'est
qu'il vienne doubler votre capacité de
stockage et ça c'est le truc qui va
vraiment être super cool et c'est
vraiment pour ça qu'il faut y aller tout
de suite c'est à dire que si vous
achetez vous la version la moins chère à
959 avec la technologie en ufs 3.1
Samsung va faire deux choses du moins
une chose la deuxième c'est la
conséquence ils vont venir doubler votre
stockage ça veut dire que vous passez du
128 et vous montez directement au 256
donc ça c'est cool déjà le stockage est
doublé et ça vous fait quand même
économiser allez pas 100 balles mais
presque mais surtout ça fait que vous
passez et ça c'est pas si long calculer
vous passez la technologie
ufs 3.1 directement vous êtes upgradé en
ufs 4.0 donc ça c'est uniquement
jusqu'au 16 février sur les précommandes
je voulais vraiment vous le montrer
parce que ça vraiment un sens ça c'est
super important si vous voulez acheter
aujourd'hui le meilleur smartphone chez
Samsung le plus performant ce n'est pas
le Samsung Galaxy S23 en 128 Go de
stockage ça commence uniquement au
Samsung Galaxy S23 en 256 Go de stockage
avec l'UFS 4.0 donc profitez-en ça vous
intéresse sur les précommandes c'est
maintenant vous y allez vous l'acheter
en 128 ils vont vous doubler le stockage
vous passez du coup de l'UFS 3.1 à l'UFS
4.0 et ça c'est beau merci qui merci
Monsieur gruau enfin c'est pas moi qui
vous le double c'est Samsung merci
également à Samsung une fois de plus je
vous mets tous les liens en bas dans la
description et je vous prends la
dernière exemple parce que je trouve
super intéressant vous savez en fait
l'autonomie d'un smartphone c'est pas
uniquement la batterie c'est d'une la
capacité de la batterie plus en plus le
processeur le SOC qui va être plus ou
moins énergivore et puis en
troisièmement c'est quoi et bien c'est
la mémoire qui joue un rôle aussi
important donc vous avez vraiment ce
triptyque plus l'expérience logiciel
voilà en plus de ça le X mais il y a pas
que ça il y a vraiment ces trois points
qui sont super importants et ça je vous
prends pour exemple ce que propose
notamment Apple avec ses iPhone ils ont
des batteries plus petites mais c'est
tellement efficient que l'autonomie est
bonne donc ici une lésinez pas sur la
technologie passez vraiment de l'UFS 3.0
et puis autre petit détail il faut
savoir que en plus de ça le F elle est 4
fois plus rapide que l'UFS 2.2 donc
lorsque vous venez regarder des
smartphones ne regardez pas uniquement
avec des écrans vous regardez la techno
à l'intérieur ça me permettra de savoir
s'il va être rapide pratique oui non
quoi comment voilà je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous on se retrouve très
bientôt pour parler bien évidemment du
S23 ultra test complet on fera la même
chose avec les S23 et S23 plus même si
on a déjà dit quand même pas mal de
choses dessus on va aller plus loin au
niveau de la photo c'est ça voilà on se
retrouve très bientôt prenez soin de
vous embrasse et dites-moi tout ce que
vous pensez de ça on va en commentaire
Ciao
[Musique]